le bruit des bombes se rapproche
alors les policiers évacuent en courant
les habitants qui fuient liman temps le
dombass
terrifiés ils sont soulagés de quitter
leur ville
c'est très difficile à cause des
bombardements constants al-iman nous
devons évacuer car nous ne savons pas ce
qui va se passer dans le futur la moitié
de la ville est détruite
une situation très dangereuse qui
inquiète le maire de cette cité ouvrière
sur place pour aider
la situation est de pire en pire ils ont
commencé à bombarder à 3 heures du matin
notre ville est séparé en deux nord et
sud et maintenant ils vont battre
complètement le sud
selon lui 22 des 40 hameaux alentours
ont été pris en une semaine liman est
importante pour les russes c'est la
dernière ville à prendre avant d'arriver
à sauvian sq l'une des principales
agglomérations de la région alors les
russes continuent l'offensive et les
évacuations se poursuivent dans la
terreur
je conduis très très vite parce que j'ai
très peur ils bombardent tellement que
des bombes tombent pendant que vous
conduisez et vous ne savez pas où elles
vont tomber
vidée de ses habitants lyman commence à
avoir des allures de ville fantôme
les autorités continuent d'amener du
pain aux rares civils sur place pour
tenir le siège merci selon l'institut
américain pour l'étude de la guerre les
russes continuent de mener de nombreux
assauts au sol dans la région dont
beaucoup restent infructueuses